[Music]
what advice would you give to your past
self if you're just entering the
recruitment industry okay be resilient
don't let the troughs out the beats and
troughs get you down super important be
the best that you can be be the best out
of everyone around you know that it's
going to be hard and the hardest part is
when you start
um and
make friends with everyone network what
did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on this sounds
really boring but probably just like
buying nappies and basically buying
stuff on my child but i do remember
buying a car i always had cars i
remember buying a really nice car so
yeah i'd say probably that what
non-negotiable do you live by each day
that you feel has a massive impact on
your productivity planning so i always
go the night before i don't plan
everything now because i do a lot of
sales still i don't plan every single
hour to the tea because i have to leave
buffers but i have core things i have to
make sure i've done so i plan always the
night for final question how do you
think we can change the perception of
the recruitment industry
i do not think anybody should be doing
anything in terms of how they work as a
recruiter what i do think people should
be doing is being proud proud of them
being a recruiter like actually saying
like yeah i work in recruitment you know
it's not a crap industry you actually so
many people don't make it in recruitment
that tells you itself that if you're in
recruitment and you're doing well well
you're doing actually pretty good just
be proud of what it is that you do like
shout about it and actually re make
everyone realize that recruitment is a
reputable industry to be in and you can
earn good money and it's not for
everyone but not everyone's successful
meaning that you're funny great
you